Welcome to our video on cloud engineer
interview questions cloud computing has
revolutionized The Way businesses
operate and as a result the demand for
skilled Cloud Engineers is on the rise
if you're aspiring to become a cloud
engineer so you have come to the right
place in this video we'll be discussing
some of the most commonly asked
interview questions for cloud Engineers
providing you with valuable insights and
tips on how to answer them effectively
so let's Dive Right In one of the key
areas you will be quizzed on is your
knowledge of cloud providers Cloud
giants like Amazon web services Google
Cloud platform and Microsoft Azure
dominate the industry along with the
knowledge of various Services provided
by these Cloud platforms is crucial
employers will want to know about your
experience with these platforms such as
deploying and managing resources
configuring security and optimizing
performances Cloud Engineers often
collaborate closely with devops teams so
basic knowledge of devops and its
related Concepts is essential now let's
add some solid data to support the
significance of cloud engineering
according to a recent survey by write
scale 94 of Enterprises are using Cloud
infrastructure in some form
and according to recent data from
Glassdoor the average pays pay for cloud
Engineers is around 115
000 per year in the USA
so in our Cloud engineer interview
questions video we'll cover these
important topics and more so without any
further delay let's embark on this
knowledge packed journey and get started
but before that if you want to learn
about cloud computing and its Concepts
to build the base of your career then
simply learns Caltech postgraduate
program in cloud computing can help you
with that this postgraduate program in
cloud computing designed in
collaboration with caltex cdme will help
you become an expert in Azure AWS and
gcp this in-depth cloud computing
certification course will let you master
key architectural principles and develop
the skills needed to become a cloud
expert
it will help you become an expert in
designing planning and scaling cloud
implementations
our cloud computing course helps you
master the core skill set required to
design and deploy dynamically scalable
and reliable applications on three
popular Cloud platforms providers
Microsoft Azure AWS and gcp so why wait
check out the course Link in the
description now let's get started with
the video but before dealing with the
questions let's first understand what is
cloud computing cloud computing is the
delivery of Computing Services over the
Internet it provides on-demand access to
Shared resources like servers and
Storage
users can scale resources as needed and
only pay for what they use
it offers benefits like cost efficiency
scalability and accessibility there are
different service model like
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service and software as a service
however it also comes with
considerations like security and
internet connectivity
now let's understand the role of a cloud
engineer
well a cloud engineer is a professional
responsible for Designing implementing
and managing cloud-based infrastructure
and services
they specialize in deploying and
maintaining cloud computing solutions to
meet the specific needs of organizations
well the role of a cloud engineer
involves Cloud architecture design that
means accessing business requirements
and designing cloud-based solutions that
align with organizational goals this
includes determining the appropriate
cloud service models and selecting the
right cloud provider
second is cloud infrastructure
deployment
this involves implementing and
configuring the necessary Cloud
infrastructure components such as
virtual machines storage networks and
security measures this involves setting
up and optimizing Cloud resources for
performance scalability and reliability
then comes Automation and orchestration
developing automation scripts and tools
to streamline Cloud deployment
management and monitoring possesses
comes under this this include using
infrastructure as code technique to
automate infrastructure provisioning and
configuration
then comes Cloud security and compliance
this ensures the security and compliance
of cloud environments by implementing
appropriate security measures assess
controls and encryption protocols this
may involve managing identity and access
management policies implementing data
encryption and monitoring for potential
vulnerabilities
then comes performance monitoring and
optimization
monitoring Cloud infrastructure
performance identifying bottlenecks or
issues and optimizing resource
allocation for efficient operation comes
under this
this includes analyzing Cloud usage
patterns and making recommendations for
cost optimization
and after this comes collaboration and
support
collaborating with cross-functional
teams such as developers system
administrators and network Engineers to
provide support and resolve any Cloud
related issues Cloud engineer may also
assist in training and guiding teams on
cloud best practices
will Cloud Engineers typically possess a
combination of technical skills
including knowledge of cloud platforms
such as Amazon web services Microsoft
Azure or Google Cloud platform
proficiency and scripting or programming
languages understanding of networking
Concepts and experience with
infrastructure and application
deployment
but remember becoming a cloud engineer
is a journey that requires dedication
hands-on experience and a commitment to
continuous learning
now that we have an overview of how to
become a cloud engineer let's focus on
how to prepare for it here are some top
Cloud engineering interview questions
and answers that will help you prepare
better for your interview
let's start with the basic level first
so now that we have an overview of how
to become a cloud engineer let's focus
on how to prepare for it here are some
top Cloud engineer interview questions
and answers that will help you prepare
better for your interview
so let's start with the basic level
first
question one is what is cloud list some
different versions of cloud
so the answer is cloud computing refers
to the integration of networks Hardware
Services storage and interfaces for
delivering Computing as a service it
involves three primary users end users
cloud service providers and business
management users
different types of cloud deployment
exist including multi-cloud public Cloud
private cloud and hybrid Cloud coming to
the question number two is what is meant
by function as a service
so the correct answer is function as a
service offers users a platform where
they can develop manage and run their
applications without worrying about the
infrastructure's maintenance coming to
the question number three is Define the
various cloud storage levels well the
correct answer is level of data storage
that cloud storage device mechanisms
offer are files that batches of data
grouped into files located in folders
blocks the smallest unit of data that
can be accessed individually is known as
a block the lowest level of storage and
closest to the hardware
data sets these are data sets that have
been divided and organized into a
tabular delimited or recorded format
objects refers to the data and the
related metadata organized as web-based
resources now coming to the question
number four is what are some of the key
features of cloud computing well the
answer is agility helps in quick and
inexpensive reprovisioning of resources
location Independence this means that
the resources can be accessed from
anywhere
multi-tenancy the resources are shared
amongst a large group of users
reliability resources and computation
can be Dependable for accessibility and
scalability dynamic provisioning of data
helps in scaling
question number five is what you mean by
Cloud delivery models well Cloud
delivery models are models that
represent the Computing environments
these are as follows infrastructure as a
service is the delivery of services
including an operating system storage
networking and various utility software
elements on a request basis
platform as a service platform as a
service is a mechanism for combining
infrastructure as a service with an
abstracted set of middleware services
software development and deployment
tools these allow the organizations to
have a consistent way to create and
deploy applications on a cloud or on
premises environment software as a
service is a business application
created and hosted by a provider in a
multi-tenant model
and function as a service gives a
platform for customers to build manage
and run app functionalities without the
difficulty of maintaining infrastructure
one can thus achieve a serverless
architecture
coming to the question number six is
what are the main constituents that are
part of the cloud ecosystem
well the parts of the cloud ecosystem
that determine how you view the cloud
architecture are Cloud consumers direct
customers and cloud service providers
now coming to the question number seven
that is who are the cloud service
providers in a cloud ecosystem
well the answer is cloud service
providers are the commercial vendors or
companies that create their own
capabilities the commercial vendors sell
their services to Cloud consumers in
contrast to this a company might decide
to become an internal cloud service
provided to its own Partners employees
and customers either as an internal
service or as a profit Center
cloud service providers also create
applications or services for such
environments question 8 is describe the
cloud computing architecture
the answer is the architecture of cloud
computing encompasses the interconnected
components that form a cloud model this
illustrates the relationships between
different cloud services catering to the
requirement of businesses on the left
side the cloud service consumer
represent the various ways in which
cloud services are utilized regardless
of specific user demands it is crucial
to assemble the appropriate service
capable of supporting both internal and
external users consumer management
should enable the Swift availability of
services to meet evolving business needs
this category includes applications
middleware infrastructure and services
built on premises Computing models
Additionally the model highlights the
role of a cloud auditor either internal
or external responsible for overseeing
the consumer group to ensure compliance
with obligations question 9 is who are
the cloud consumers in a cloud ecosystem
well the correct answer is the
individuals and groups within your
business unit that use different types
of cloud services to get a task
accomplished a cloud consumer could be a
developer using compute services from a
public cloud
question 10 is who are the Direct
customer in a cloud ecosystem well the
answer is users who often take advantage
of services that your business has
created within a cloud environment the
end users of your service have no idea
that you are using a public or private
Cloud as long as the users are concerned
they're interacting directly with the
services and value now let's move to the
intermediate level of Cloud engineer
interview questions
the question one in this category is
what are Cloud enabling Technologies
there are several areas of technology
that contribute to modern day
cloud-based platforms these are known as
Cloud enabling Technologies some of the
cloud enabling Technologies are
Broadband network and internet
architecture Data Center Technology
virtualization technology web technology
multi-tenant technology and service
technology question two is what are
serverless components in cloud computing
well the answer is serverless components
in cloud computing allows the building
of applications to take place without
the complexity of managing the
infrastructure one can write code
without having provision to a server
serverless machines take care of virtual
machines and container management
multi-threading Hardware allocating are
also taken care of by the serverless
components question three is what is an
API Gateway well an API Gateway allows
multiple apis to act together as a
single gateway to provide a uniform
experience to the user in this each API
call is processed reliably the API
Gateway manages the API centrally and
provides Enterprise grade security
common tasks of the API Services can be
handled by the API Gateway these tasks
include services like the statistics
rate limiting and user Authentication
4 is what do you mean by encapsulation
in cloud computing
well a container is Packet software code
along with all of its dependencies so
that it can run consistently across
clouds and on-premises
this packaging up of code is often
called encapsulation encapsulating code
is important for developers as they
don't have to develop code based on each
individual environment
question 5 is what are the different
data centers deployed for cloud
computing
so cloud computing is made up of various
data centers put together in a great
form it consists of the data centers
like containerized Data Center and low
density Data Center
question 6 is what are containerized
data centers so the containerized data
centers are the traditional data centers
that allow a high level of
customizations with servers mainframes
and other resources these require
planning cooling networking and power to
access and work question 7 is what are
low density data centers now the low
density data centers are optimized to
give high performance the space
constraint is being removed and there is
an increased density in these data
centers one drawback it has is that with
high density the heat issue also Creeps
in these data centers are quite suitable
to develop the cloud infrastructure
question 8 is what are Cloud native
applications well Cloud native is a
software framework designed with
containers microservices Dynamic
orchestration and also continuous
delivery of software every part of the
cloud native application has within it
its own container and is dynamically
orchestrated with other containers to
optimize the way the resource are
utilized now the question number nine is
what do you mean by rate limiting well
rate limiting is a way to limit the
network traffic rate limiting runs
within the app rather than the server it
typically tracks the IP addresses and
the time between each request it can
eliminate certain suspicious and
malicious activities
what's that impact a website can also be
stopped by rate limiting this protects
against API overuse which is important
to prevent
so now that we have covered Basics and
intermediate level let's move on to the
advanced level question one is what is
cloud usage monitor the cloud usage
monitor is an autonomous lightweight
software application that is responsible
for Gathering and processing the it
resource utilization data Cloud usage
monitors may exist in various formats
depending on the kind of usage metrics
these are designed to gather and how the
usage data needs to be collected
the three typical agent based
implementation formats are monitoring
agent resource agent and polling agent
question two is how does the monitoring
agent monitor Cloud usage well a
monitoring agent is a service agent that
exists as an intermediate and an even
driven application that resides
alongside the current communication
channels
it examines and transparently monitors
data flows the monitoring agent is
frequently used to gauge message metrics
as well as Network traffic
question 3 is how does the resource
agent monitor the cloud usage well a
processing module that is used to
collect usage data by having even driven
interactions with a specialized resource
software is a resource agent this agent
is applied to check the usage metrics
based on predefined observable events at
the resource software level like
initiating suspending resuming and
vertical scaling
question four is how does the polling
agent monitor Cloud usage now a polling
agent is a processing component that
collects information about how cloud
services are used by polling ID
resources the polling agent has also
been used to promptly track the uptime
and downtime of ID resources
question 5 is what are microservices
well microservices is a process of
developing applications that consist of
code that is independent of each other
and of the underlying developing
platform
each microservice runs a unique process
and communicates through well-defined
and standardized apis once created these
services are defined in the form of a
catalog so that developers can easily
locate the right service and also
understand the governance rules of usage
question 6 is why are microservices
important for a true Cloud environment
the reasons why microservices are so
important for a two Cloud environment is
because of these four key benefits each
microservice is built to serve a
specific and limited purpose and hence
application development is simplified
small development teams can then focus
on writing code for some of the narrowly
defined and easily understood functions
second code changes will be smaller and
less complex than with a complex
integrated application making it easier
and faster to make changes whether to
fix a problem or to upgrade service with
new requirements
third is scalability now scalability
makes it easier to deploy an additional
instance of a service or change that
service as needs evolve
fourth microservices are fully tested
and validated when new applications
leverage existing microservices
developers can assume the Integrity of
the new application without the need of
continual testing
question 7 is what is meant by Edge
Computing so agent Cloud are
complementary these are both parts of a
broader concept called the distributed
Cloud a majority of those pursuing Edge
Computing strategies are now viewing
Edge as part of their overall Cloud
strategy Edge Computing unlike cloud
computing is all about the physical
location and issues related to latency
cloud and Edge combines the strengths of
a centralized system along with the
advantages of distributed operations at
the physical location where things and
people can connect
in iot scenarios The Edge is very common
cloud is different from the edge in that
it has never been about location as
opposed it has always been about the
independence of location
the popular scenarios are where you have
cloud and Edge together and the cloud
providers control to run and defines the
architecture for what is out at the edge
question 8 is how does resource
replication take place in cloud
computing well resource replication is
the creation of multiple instances of
the same I.T resource it is typically
performed when an I.T resources
availability and performance are needed
to be enhanced the virtualization
technology is adopted to implement the
resource replication mechanism in order
to replicate the cloud-based it
resources question 9 is what are the
advantages of serverless computing well
serverless Computing has the following
advantages it is cost effective and the
operations on serverless Computing are
simplified
serverless Computing helps boost
productivity and offers scaling options
which involves zero server management
question 10 is what are the
disadvantages of serverless computing
the serverless code can cause response
latency it is not ideal for high
Computing operations because of resource
limitations
also for serverless computing the
responsibility of security comes under
the service company and not the consumer
which might be more vulnerable
and debugging serverless code is a bit
more challenging
so there you go these are some of the
most common Cloud engineer interview
questions that you might come across
while giving an interview also here's an
inspiring success story from A Satisfied
Learners who have propelled their
careers with cloud computing this can
help you boost your confidence and help
you make a firm decision in this field
I'm coming I'm currently living I wanted
to experience what is like to live I
also realized that to get a new job I
needed to have a professional
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing in association with
culture with this course I had the
choice to study while I continue and
that is how I got this new job offer
with 60 percent salary high in Finland I
will be leading the cloud computing unit
we cannot wait to start our new life in
Finland we are all well this was all
about this video If you like this video
then please do give it a thumbs up and
share it with your friends also if you
have any questions then please feel free
to ask me in the comment section our
team will reach out to you as soon as
possible thank you and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign